some people fit right in it comes  effortlessly it must be nice no excuse  me  can you buy some booze for my friends  and I oh there's my girl  this never happened hey you guys want a  party like rock stars follow me  cool basement you're free to do what  everyone down here but nobody go  upstairs this is so sick  welcome to Mars who are you with just  some kids from school  you got a sweet mama huh hi honey I want  you to meet someone ma why don't you get  our numbers I told you everyone is here  we can't go up there  what the hell take a look at Maggie I  can feel those big doe eyes watching me  why is my son spending time at your  house some people fit right in strip  what you did to me boy how does it feel  to be on the outside looking in it's the  most fun I've had in a long time  [Music]  you